bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du nouvel ipad d'apple l'ipad de 2018
avec un écran 9,7 pouces et s'en va le
regarder maintenant nouvel ipad pour
apple il ya effectivement une
présentation ya pa très très longtemps
au mois de mars 2018 pour parler des
questions d'éducation et qui dit
éducation des nouveaux produits pour les
enseignants pour les étudiants et pour
pas mal de monde d'ailleurs donc
justement par ce sont tout de suite sur
la présentation de ce nouvel ipad en a
eu plein de questions sur l'éducation ça
on en parlera peut-être plus tard pour
l'instant surtout montré vraiment sur ce
nouveau produit ce nouvel est pas de
savoir si l'intérêt 106 vaut le coup il
faut l'acheter oui ou non
et puis en plus qui a dans le ventre
parce que la gamme et paillettes une
gamme qui est très très très l'âge on
vante pas griller dans une prochaine
vidéo très prochainement pour savoir
quel ipad acheté en 2018 sans nom pas
dans quelques jours donc je vous invite
à vous abonner
si vous souhaitez acheter un ipad et
vous n'êtes pas forcément le cas
l'acheter on a un petit peu débrouiller
tout ça parce que vous allez voir il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de produits
il faut c'est un peu compliqué de se
repérer d'or en attendant tout de suite
on m'a parlé de ce nouvel ipad ne valait
pas dès qu'un écran retina 9,7 pouces on
reste un peu dans les standards ce qui
avait chez apple avant au niveau cet
écran la vraie différence va se faire
qu'avec ce nouveau produit
vous pouvez utiliser l'apple pencil le
style et le fameux style et qu on trouve
dans l'ipad pro dans les ipad pro parce
que là plusieurs et ça c'est une grande
avancée c'est vraiment intéressant alors
que fait d'avoir l'iphone peine s'il
n'est pas la seule avancée on a aussi un
processeur plus puissant
on se retrouve avec le à 10 fusion qu'on
retrouve dans l'iphone 5 et l'iphone
cette plus donc une machine est quand
même sur booster plus puissante et qui
vous permettre de faire beaucoup plus de
choses et qui va ouvrir un petit peu les
horizons alors elle a des points très
positifs à commencer par la puissance
par le prix toutes ces choses là on va
les détailler et des points aussi
négatif puisque qui dit apple pencil 10
produits que vous allez acheter
en supplément dit surcoûts dus au final
sa taille patte de 2018 et à ses abords
d'un autre niveau du tarif
mais dès que vous voulez rajouter les
options qui vont bien à vous coûter
beaucoup plus cher à qui se destine ce
produit est dédié pour la créative
et la productivité à des infographistes
a un côté un peu plus amateur pour
utilisation du paint si l'on n'est pas
comme sur l'ipad pro comme sur les ipad
pro on s'adresse vraiment un des
architectes on s'adresse vraiment à des
illustrateurs professionnels non là on
s'adresse vraiment à des personnes qui
ont l'utilité d'un stylet mais qui donc
pas forcément mais beaucoup d'argent ou
pris en tout cas non pas le besoin tout
de suite de mettre beaucoup d'argent qui
n'auront pas le retour sur
investissement notamment sur
l'investissement d'un ipad progrès coûte
tout de suite beaucoup plus cher donc si
on envie d'utiliser un stylet si on en a
besoin sinon on à l'utilité cet ipad de
2018 peut être très intéressant est
notamment destiné aux étudiants pour le
dessin la prise de notes manuscrites
toutes ces choses là c'est vraiment
super intéressant alors on n'aura pas
exactement les mêmes points de détails
qu'on retrouve dans un ipad pro mais
déjà ça sera vraiment le job autre point
intéressant en estrie pad c'est la
réalité augmentée alors aujourd'hui la
réalité augmentée c'est plus du gadget
mais lorsqu'on mal et son usage un peu
plus professionnel probablement son ipad
promet déjà sur cet iphone on va pouvoir
l'utiliser pour la conception de la
réalisation pour de la modélisation il
se rend compte un petit peu dans un
environnement ce que donne un objet
qu'on a réalisé virtuellement il ya pas
mal d'applications qui vont pouvoir se
faire notamment au niveau du
professionnel pour la réalité augmentée
donc ça peut être vraiment un premier
point si on leur en usage pro d'utiliser
sa taille pas de 2018 on va pas se
mentir par rapport au budget de l'année
dernière et sera forcément plus précis
au niveau tactile que vous utilisiez
votre doigt au bout utilisiez l'ipod
d'apple peine s'ils ont plus de 5 et
technologique est assez intéressant
lorsque vous avez utilisé le pencil une
détection de la paume de la main
vous allez pouvoir poser votre main
directement sur l'écran sans que ceux
reconnus comme une zone tactile ça me
servira notamment d'appui pour décider
pour faire des choses qui sont assez
précise et ça c'est franchement pas
négligeable côté esthétique on retrouve
un design un peu classique au niveau des
ipad il ya peu une grande révolution on
attend un ipad pro de cette année qui
pour arriver avec un écran bord à bord
voir comment pour intégrer faille s'est
dit dans tout ça et encore pas mal de
points d'interrogation mais
effectivement on voit que sa taille pas
de là qui est annoncé au mois de mars
2018 ne change pas d'un point de vue
esthétique on retrouve cette grande
banlieue tout autour on a un boîtier en
aluminium à l'europe après il est dans
les standards il fait le job le plutôt
séduisant enfin bref rien de bien
surprenant rien de bien d'un go il fait
la faire ce qui est très intéressant que
ça c'est que apple nous dit que pour eux
l'ipad c'est la vision du futur de
l'ordinateur ce qui paraît assez vrai si
vous voulez c'est que bien évidemment
avec les ipad ou avec les tablettes un
peu classique on a un écran tactile
ah ça vous allait rajouter un clavier un
style et pourquoi pas et vous allez
effectivement un petit ordinateur
tactile
on parle bien évidement d'ordinateurs
personnels en parle pas d'ordinateur à
usage professionnel avec beaucoup de
capacités de calcul dans certaines
applications notamment les gros
application montage et des choses comme
ça donc ça pour l'instant on n'en parle
pas mais effectivement ça me paraît
assez juste que de dire ce système d'
ipad ce système de tablettes va
remplacer demain nos ordinateurs
personnels alors après par extension il
ya plein de choses derrière notamment
avec les écrans pliables enfin son nom
apparaît un peu plus tard donc rester
connecté parce que c'est tous des choses
qui vont arriver
il ya certaines choses à dire dessus
vous allez voir c'est très intéressant
mais bon là on la sentait tout de suite
sur l'ipad donc pour apple c'est
effectivement la définition de ce que
pourrait être l'ordinateur de demain et
notamment en y ajoutant un clavier
côté technologie qui a rien de bien d'un
go vous avez une caméra arrière de 8
mégapixels vous pouvez enregistrer en
full hd
vous pouvez scanner des documents
directement dans l'application notes
vous avez les applis pages numbers
keynote qui sont compatible avec l'apple
pencil donc ça c'est vrai que c'est
plutôt pas mal pour votre travail en
termes de prise de notes alors je ne
sais pas si aujourd'hui tout le monde
utilise ses applications est ce qu'elles
sont beaucoup utilisés est ce qu'elles
sont pas beaucoup plus utilisé une ne
semble en tout cas que les applications
du pack office de microsoft sont
beaucoup plus utilisés
il ne sent également dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire que les
applications google sont assez utilisé
pour tout ce qui va être traitement de
texte puisqu'il va être tableur je ne
sais pas si les applications d'apple
aujourd'hui sont beaucoup utilisés
dites moi ce que vous en pensez parce
que moi pour ma part en tout cas je ne
les utilise pas néanmoins maintenant
quand pouvoir les utiliser avec l'apple
pencil peut-être que ça va amener un peu
plus de monde à les utiliser en tout cas
un vrai sens à noter également vous
faire des montages audio travail et de
la musique directement avec votre appel
pencil dans garageband et également du
montage vidéo avec imovie alors on est
sur des montages amateur face au
démontage professionnels mais déjà pour
s'amuser faire des petits pattern faire
un peu de musique ou un peu de montage
vidéo
pourquoi pas utiliser l'apple pencil ça
peut être intéressant bien évidemment on
retrouve le
touch et d'ipad faith heidi sur cet
appareil là de toute façon c'est un
appareil qui se veut abordable pas
forcément cher pour les produits d'apple
donc il est très clair que la nouvelle
technologie de déverrouillage faïdi n'a
pas sa place dedans pour l'instant en
tout cas le pencil d'apple va très bien
avec qu'il est sensible à la pression
très réactif très fin très facile
d'utilisation
après effectivement et coûte 99 euros
c'est tout de suite un investissement
parce que justement on va parler du prix
alors je vous donnais les tarifs
il faut savoir quand même que cet ipad
est disponible dans deux versions une
version wifi et une version wifi + 4 g
pour la version wifi vous le trouvez à
359 euros en 32 gigas et vous allez le
trouver en version wifi + 4 g à 489
euros
si maintenant vous voulez passer en 128
giga il vous coûtera 4 149 euros en
version wi fi et 579 euros en version
wifi et 4g à ça il faut bien évidemment
rajouter les 99 euros de l'apple bensid
si vous voulez utiliser le stylet c'est
d'ailleurs fait tout l'intérêt de ce
produit autre point intéressant si vous
voulez utiliser un clavier il vous
coûtera 70 euros pour avoir un clavier
vous allez branché uniquement en
bluetooth parce que vous n'avez pas le
système de branchement qu'on trouvait
sur l'ipad pro exemple tout bête vous
prenez l'ipad wifi 4g en 128 giga qui
coûte 5 179 euros
vous rajoutez les 99 euros de l'apple
pencil plus les 70 euros du clavier vous
retrouver quand même à 748 euros
donc effectivement là j'étais pris
effectivement un modèle le plus cher je
fais un petit peu je me rappelle
l'avocat du diable mais vous vous
retrouvez quand même un produit qui
coûte le prix d'un ipad frau d'un ipad
pro or clavier et or paintsil
mais tout compte le calcul et en terme
de budget on voit que si on arrive tout
de suite dans les produits avec le plus
de stockage et le plus d'options et plus
de performance tout de suite ce qu'il
est censé pas cher à la base peut
rapidement coûter cher alors maintenant
quelles sont les plus quels sont les
mots alors pour moi les plus c'est très
clairement le fait de pouvoir avoir un
style et un apple pencil sur un produit
pas cher en ipad pas cher les vents
guillemets quand je dis pas chercher
apple mais en tout cas un produit
abordable pour un ipad abordable ça
s'est vraiment bien
deuxième point qui est super intéressant
c'est l'augmentation de la puissance on
se retrouve avec effectivement un
processeur à 10
fusion je vous ai déjà dit qui équipe
les iphone 7 et les iphone c'est plus
donc ça s'est vraiment bien ça c'est le
point positif si vous voulez dire qu'en
achetant aujourd'hui un nouvel ipad si
vous en avez besoin si vous avez pas un
ipad qui est trop ancien descendre
appareils d'ici quelques instants
ce qui est vraiment intéressant c'est
que vous allez avoir un produit qui va
être vraiment dans les normes du jour
qui a vous permettre de voir un petit
peu venir dans le temps parce que les
produisent des modes assez rapidement
c'est un peu moins vrai chez les ipad
que chez les iphone vous avez une durée
de vie qui est un peu plus longue donc
un parc qui se remplacent beaucoup moins
vite du point de vue du particulier par
contre faut faire gaffe parce que si
vous avez un ipad qui a quelques années
comme et à jour votre os vous pouvez
rapidement avoir une machine qui rament
et si vous l'utilisez les dernières
applications
il nous faudra un os récents si vous
faites vos mises à jour vous allez avoir
une machine qui peut ramer c'est ce qui
n'arrive évoque mois avec un ancien
n'aille pas n'y a pas très longtemps
j'ai dû faire une mise à jour d'ios pour
utiliser une application intéressante la
machine s'est mise à ramé est devenu
très pénible à utiliser parce qu'on
passe un temps de dingue de six
canadiens sur safari enfin ça devenait
vraiment hyper compliqué donc il est
très important d'avoir une machine qui
est quand même assez performante qui a
pouvoir être compatible avec les os du
moment et les applications du moment
donc là pour moi en tout cas si vous
devez acheter un ipad si vous n'avez pas
l'ipad de 2010
attention parce que si vous avez l'ipad
et mehdi says je suis pas sûr que ce
soit intéressant d'acheter celui de 2018
le point de vue économique va pas y
avoir une grosse différence un peu plus
de puissance effectivement la possibité
avoir le style et si vous avez vraiment
besoin du stylet vous pouvez changer de
celui de 2010 est à 2018 mais sinon si
vous avez un ipad anciens ou si vous
n'avez jamais n'at il pas john mutt
tablette et que vous voulez en acheter
un là effectivement il ya un vrai sens à
acheter celui ci surtout qu'en termes de
tarifs directement nu sans le pen s'il
sent rien il est très abordable il va
coûter voire même moins chers que les
produits d'ancienne génération donc si
vous voulez en acheter un il faut pas
vous priver d'ailleurs ce qui intéresse
je vous ai mis des liens à la
description pour haifa réquisitions
alors si vous voulez l'acheter je vous
invite à passer par ce lien pas pour
m'enrichir répond permettre de faire
évoluer la chaîne de me déplacer de
pouvoir acheter du matos d'aller sur des
événements comme le cfcm qui sont très
coûteuses que je paie de ma poche mais
j'ai pas faire causette mais en tout cas
si vous lâchez ce matos vous invite à
passer par ces liens comme ça ça me
permettra de faire toujours plus de
choses et d'autres étaient toujours plus
de contenu intéressant
en fait on va parler des côtés négatifs
alors pour moi les côtés négatifs c'est
comme je vous dise
le prix si vous prenez un ipad à 359
euros ou vous rajoutez 99 euros dont il
peine s'il est que vous achetiez article
clavier logitech un connexion bluetooth
à 70 euros
c'est là qu'elle vous coûté 458 euros
donc pour avoir un produit de base qui
est censée ne pas être cher au final
vous allez vous retrouver à un produit
un petit peu moins de 500 euros voilà il
faut quand même présent le budget si on
veut utiliser correctement à fond comme
un petit ordinateur avec des guillemets
avec un pencil tout de suite il faut
néanmoins prévoir le budget il faut
savoir qu'à ce prix là vous avez accès à
des ordinateurs windows à des pc windows
en tout cas moyen de gamme qui vont être
très correct donc il ya vraiment un
choix à faire à se dire est-ce que je
vais sur un pc est-ce que je vais sur un
chromebook avec la voûte est d'ailleurs
beaucoup moins cher à l'achat qu'une
tablette apple va nier toute une
réflexion avoir là dessus mais c'est en
tout cas vous voulez vraiment avoir un
ipad vous faire plaisir l'ipad 2
d'émettre des huit mois je trouve super
séduisant alors maintenant on peut se
poser la question de la différence par
rapport à l'ipad pro parce
qu'effectivement on va plaisait pas trop
et jusqu'à présent tout cas les seules
compatible à avoir ce petit apple pencil
à avoir les claviers vous pouvez
brancher directement sur les smart
connector là effectivement il faut avoir
un clavier vous connecter en bluetooth
qui dit bluetooth dit un petit peu plus
de consommation au niveau de l'énergie
normalement vous avoir une autonomie d'à
peu près 10 heures pour une charge
complète là si vous passez en bluetooth
peut-être que l'autonomie va diminuer un
petit peu ça c'est des choses à
contrôler effectivement alors qu'elle
veuille vraiment la différence en tout
cas avec l'ipad trop et ipad là parce
qu'on va effectivement que les prix de
base ne sont pas du tout les mêmes dans
les deux cas vous utiliser l'iphone
pencil et dans les deux cas vous allez
pouvoir avoir un clavier soit branché
avec les smart connector pour l'ipad
trop soit avec un clavier bluetooth
directement avec l'ipad de 2018 alors
effectivement il ya une vraie différence
notamment au niveau du taux de
rafraîchissement avec l'ipad pro vous
avez un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz et croyez moi c'est pas
négligeable sur certaines applications
et notamment vraiment professionnel sur
de l'infographie sur du dessin sont des
archis sur pas mal de choses mais son
utilisation courante je dirais peut
utiliser un stylet couramment par des
dessins des notes des esquisses des
choses comme ça voilà je ne suis pas sûr
vous ai besoin d'aller sur le matériel
professionnel celui ci serait
intéressant mais voilà c'est en tout cas
pour l'instant un vrai grand point de
différenciation
le deuxième point c'est effectivement de
ne pas avoir les smart connecteurs dont
d'avoir un clavier en bluetooth et non
pas branché directement dessus
en gros il est quand même moins cher
qu'un ipad pro mais on va pas en avoir
la même utilité on pourra pas le pousser
dans les retraites dans les mêmes
retranchements en tout cas par rapport à
l'ipad
donc pour utilisation je dirais un peu
plus d'amateurs ou une utilisation on va
rentrer va commencer à utiliser un ipad
si l'un apple pencil c'est dur à
prononcer apple pencil voilà ça fait
vraiment la fin c'est vraiment très
intéressant
autre point qui est intéressant c'est
l'utilisation 4g je vous en parlais pour
pouvoir effectivement avoir de la data
et l'utiliser lorsqu'il est en
déplacement alors ça ça n'a d'intérêt
qu'effectivement que lorsque vous avez
vraiment besoin de data en vous
déplaçant il ya beaucoup de hotspots
beaucoup de wifi aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous avez besoin de prendre un ipad avec
le wifi et la 4g ça reste à mesurer
parce que ça coûte quand même cher alors
je vous donnais les prix parce qu'il
faut savoir
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure sont
32 gigas vous avez quand même un modèle
à 359 euros en wifi et 489 euros pour
avoir l'option kajiya quand même 130
euros d'écart entre les deux modèles
c'est pas négligeable donc avez vous
vraiment besoin de l'utiliser en version
mobilité avec la 4g ça c'est à vous de
voir
à noter qu'avec l'option carte apple sim
vous pouvez utiliser la 4g dans plus de
180 pays
donc si vous en avez besoin c'est
intéressant voilà un petit peu tout ce
que je peux vous dire que sur ce produit
alors moi sur le principe je trouve cool
et ce que je trouve super intéressant là
dedans si vous voulez c'est qu'on voit
qu'il ya une amélioration de la guyane
on voit qu'une gamme des ipad qui va
plus loin aujourd'hui chez apple c'est
très intéressant et surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir qu'ils
augmentent pas les tarifs alors qu'ils
augmentent pas les tarifs du produit
directement pour pouvoir s'adresser à un
public un peu plus jeune qui va rentrer
dans la gamme ipad donc ça s'est
vraiment bien notamment par rapport au
produit un petit peu plus anciens si
vous allez fouiller un parent droite à
gauche vous allez voir que les anciens
produits coûte le même prix voire un peu
plus cher néanmoins celui-ci l'homme
c'est très malin de la part d'apple
c'est que effectivement on a un produit
qui est très abordable et vous allez
pouvoir utiliser le stylet dessus ce qui
fait qu'apple d'augmenter
significativement son chiffre d'affaires
puisque ils vont vendre d apple stylet
et ça c'est plutôt malin ce qui fait que
lorsque vous voulez acheter ce produit
beaucoup vont être intéressés par le
style est donc vous achetez votre
produit qui à la base n'est pas trop
cher mais en rajoutant tout de suite 99
euros de stylet pour notre calme
addition vous augmentez qu'à une
addition de 100 euros voilà voilà peu
pour tout ce qu'on pouvait dire
aujourd'hui sur ce nouvel ipad
cette housse de 2018 si vous voulez
acheter un ipad si vous n'avez jamais eu
d'ipod vous pouvez y aller c'est un très
bon produit apple est vraiment des bons
ipad je peux vous le garantir maintenant
attention si vous avez un ipad de
l'année dernière ne l'achetez pas sauf
si vous avez vraiment besoin du stylet
et si vous avez un ipad prouve bien
évidemment il faut pas l'ipad pro de
toute façon est beaucoup mieux
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez ce
que vous attentez est ce que vous pensez
cet ipad un vrai sens est ce que vous
pensez qu'elle fait de pouvoir avoir un
stylet sur un ipad d'entrée de gamme est
intéressant marque qui m'a tout sans
commentaire comme dalles nous invite à
rester connectés à me laisser des jolies
pousse à vous abonner
je vais vous faire une vidéo comme je
vous disais tout à l'heure d'ici
quelques temps pour en savoir un petit
peu canaille pas d'acheter en 2018 parce
que la gamme d' ipad est quand même très
grande savoir vers quel produit il faut
se diriger plutôt qu'un autre
donc restez connectés en plus à plein de
choses dont on va parler dans les jours
qui viennent et notamment d'un probable
futur hypothétique iphone avec un écran
pliable donc sans m'en parler bientôt
rester connectés d'ici là soyez cela je
vous en masse prenez soin de vous portez
vous bien je vais y arriver et à très
bientôt
[Musique]